all right each day we get closer and
closer to the official Deadpool 3 teaser
trailer all signs point to the trailer
arriving during the Super Bowl this
upcoming Sunday on the 11th and we have
a lot of information today about the
trailer including what the official
title for the movie could be we've
pretty much just been calling it
Deadpool 3 at this point in time which
of course it is going to be but it looks
like it is not going to follow the
tradition of the last film The Last film
Deadpool 2 was simply Deadpool 2 and
based off of the new reports Deadpool 3
is not going to be Deadpool 3 that won't
be the official title it will have a
different title according to Insider
reports plus we have some new
information about what to expect from
the movie and the trailer and if you are
wondering if there is going to be a
rated R Trailer or if they are going to
kind of mellow it down to PG-13 we have
that answer for you and we'll be
covering Deadpool extensively until it's
released so be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
Deadpool videos we're also giving away a
PS5 and Xbox series X more about that at
the end of the video so in regards to
the title I've seen some people say this
online but just so everybody is aware
Once Upon a Deadpool is not the official
title of Deadpool 2 Deadpool 2 was the
actual title however of course Deadpool
was rated R so they released a PG-13
version and that version was titled Once
Upon a Deadpool and Marvel might do that
as well especially since they're Disney
it would make sense that they would do
that but of course the big question is
what is the title of Deadpool 3 if it is
not going to be simply Deadpool 3 well
yesterday The Insider cryptic HD quality
who has a great track record with the
Scoops that they've released reported a
lot on Deadpool 3 including this
Deadpool 3 is guaranteed to feature a
Super Bowl spot with a trailer releasing
afterwards no more speculations #
Deadpool 3 # Super Bowl this is the
first time that we've heard from an
Insider that the trailer is actually
confirmed cryptic HD qual has said that
it was rumored up until this point but
now it looks like everything is a go so
I'm fully expecting the trailer to come
out this weekend on Sunday now they've
implied that the title of the film is
going to be either Deadpool and friend
or Deadpool and Wolverine they tweeted
Deadpool and friend with a photo of
Wolverine and Deadpool but people are
speculating that instead of just saying
friend they will actually say Wolverine
now what's interesting is that there is
a picture of Kevin feige at the Saturn
Awards a couple of days ago wearing a
Deadpool 3 hat we can see a new logo on
the front which is half Deadpool half
Wolverine but then we have a picture
from the back where you can see the back
of the hat which seemingly has the
Deadpool 3 title on it unfortunately
this is the best photo we have and it's
not a very good photo we can clearly see
that there is a title there but nobody
has seemed to be able to make it out
however it's speculated that it might
just read Deadpool 3 cast and crew
because we assume Kevin FY is probably
smarter than that to release the
Deadpool 3 Title by mistake by showing
his hat during an award show and a lot
of times when these hats and shirts and
Etc are given they do say cast and crew
24 or the year that they worked on it so
this could say cast and crew 24 cast and
crew 23 depending on which year they go
with they worked on most of it during 23
but they ended in 24 so it could be
either and it kind of does look like it
says cast and crew it definitely does
doesn't look like it says Deadpool and
friend or Deadpool and Wolverine so
either it says Deadpool cast and crew
and then the year or the title is not
Deadpool and Wolverine however right now
thanks to the hints by cryptic HD
quality a lot of people do believe that
the title will simply just be Deadpool
and Wolverine because that is what the
movie is about the Friendship of
Deadpool and Wolverine and also the
conflict of Deadpool and Wolverine yes
we have heard what is going to happen in
this movie there are going to be a lot
of different cameos there is Multiverse
hopping so it makes sense but at the
core the movie really is about Deadpool
and about Wolverine so let's not forget
that and let me know what you think if
this is the title do you like it do you
not would you change it or it's fine
because it's just the title of the movie
let me know in the comments down below
now cryptic HD quality did State we are
getting a redband trailer and this is
true Deadpool fashion they've always
done this for Deadpool and Deadpool 2
they've had both versions of the trailer
the Red Band The Rated R Trailer and
then the PG-13 trailer and according to
cryptic HD quality we are getting both a
red band and a green band trailer and we
do have a little bit more information
about some characters that are going to
appear in Deadpool 3 but I just want to
state that having a red band trailer and
a green band trailer is a really really
great thing because it means that Disney
is not messing with the core of Deadpool
at the core of Deadpool is really Ryan
Reynolds and his writing and that
writing we've seen through Deadpool 1
and Deadpool 2 it's r it's super comedic
it's violent it's what makes the
Deadpool movies great and a lot of
people were worried that Disney was
going to dial that down because it's now
Under the Disney umbrella but this is a
great sign that they are not holding
back with this movie which is fantastic
because when you have a movie with
Deadpool and Wolverine where they're
going to fight each other where Hugh
Jackman and Ryan Reynolds have already
teased us showing that they are going to
be stabbing each other in the face and
in the back and in the head you don't
want that water you don't want that to
be PG-13 because you're not going to get
all the same action you're also not
going to get all the snarky and crude
lines that they're going to say to each
other so Disney and Marvel Studios
recently has been making a big push to
make their content better quality and I
think this is a really good statement
that they really are trying to do that
by releasing a red band trailer and a
green band trailer now just to clarify
from what we've heard the TV spot or the
Big Game Spot during the Super Bowl is
going to be just that a TV spot it's
going to be kind of bre brief but at the
end they'll probably say something like
see the full trailer online because what
we've heard is after the TV spot on
YouTube they will release the full
teaser trailer for Deadpool 3 so be
aware of that what you see during the
Super Bowl is not the full thing now one
of the last things that cryptic HD
talked about in regards to the movie and
the trailer was about people who were
going to appear in the movie apparently
it was their birthday couple days ago
and they said appreciate the birthday
love everyone had a belated celebration
with Vanessa blind Al dopinder Colossus
shatter star negasonic Yukio Peter and
the biker dude from the bar and yes some
of those people mentioned died in
Deadpool 2 but remember the ending he
went back in time and undid a lot which
is primarily why he's going to be in
trouble with the TVA in Deadpool 3 but
keep in mind the plot synopsis that we
have currently for Deadpool 3 it reads
after facing some professional setbacks
while going through a midlife crisis
Wade Wilson decides to officially
retired Deadpool and becomes a used car
salesman but when his friends family and
the whole world are at stake Deadpool
decides to bring his katanas out of
retirement he recruits an unwilling and
wary Wolverine to not only fight for
their survival But ultimately their
legacy so his friends and his family are
going to be a decent part of at least
the beginning of the movie and probably
all throughout as well because he's
going to essentially save his world or
at least try to for them ultimately his
world probably won't be saved Saed
because of course it's in the fox
universe but hopefully all of his
friends and the family that he has go to
the MCU with him or at least a void in
the Multiverse where they're not all
destroyed by the fox Universe coming to
an end so these people probably will
appear in the teaser trailer because
they're probably going to tease that his
universe is falling apart and in order
to save it he needs to find Wolverine so
a lot to look forward to in regards to
Deadpool 3 this Sunday we should be
getting that trailer let me know how
pumped you are for it in the comments
down below and what would you like to
see from the trailer leave your thoughts
in the comments please don't forget to
like the video and subscribe to stay up
to date on Deadpool 3 and the MCU we're
also doing a giveaway for a chance to
win a PS5 and Xbox series X some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items all you
have to do is subscribe and leave a
comment down below we pick one random
comment from one random video at the end
of each month and the winner gets to
pick one item you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
wolf